hey at seven I believe that it's
important to thank the people in your
life who have helped make your life
exceptional and your business
exceptional because it's hard running
the company and we have to rely on other
people to help us out so I thought I
would create a regular series thanking
the people in my life and hopefully it
inspires you to thank and recognize the
people in yours as well let them know
that hey we appreciate all the work
you've done to help us get to where we
are so today this is a big one I want to
thank my parents now my parents have
always been super supportive of
everything that I've done in my career
even growing up all the things that I
wanted to do they are not entrepreneurs
themselves but they always supported my
business ideas I remember one of my
first ideas was to buy and sell baseball
cards I had a huge passion for baseball
and love going and buying cards and
selling amount of profit and I remember
maybe once a month going up to this
place called the orange tent that was
maybe two and a half three hours away
from my house and they would drive me
there and they would look around but the
main reason I went there was because
there was this store this little shop
set up within the orange tank where they
sold baseball cards and I would always
get excited forward and bring my money
and bring my cards and haggle and
negotiate and and you know I was maybe
ten years old and I would negotiate you
know down to the last nickel or dime and
it was it was my early days of
entrepreneurship but negotiation and my
parents had no idea about baseball cards
they didn't really care about baseball
cards but they saw that their son had a
passion for something and they were
extremely helpful and supportive in
helping me you know foster that and so
I'm really appreciative I remember
probably the hardest moment ever in my
business career was in my first real
company was a software company and you
know wasn't making the money wanted to
make barely surviving struggling to get
by having disagreements with my partners
and I remember one day in particular
where I was having a family dinner so is
at home and my pen
house and I got into an argument with my
business partner we had been struggling
for so long and we both had the same
goal born and see our company succeed we
just had different visions on how to do
it what to do next and I think when
you're just struggling and struggling
for so long you get frustrated and you
start to snap at each other and after
the call you know at the end of the call
I said like this is it I quit I don't
want to do this anymore this business is
is just taking too much of me and I
don't see how we're gonna make it and
and that's it like I can't do this
anymore I'm quitting and I felt like
such a failure after that you know like
I put all this work and effort into it
and and to hear me say that I quit felt
like such a such a failure such a down
moment in my life was like the lowest
I've ever been in my life and I hung up
the phone on my partner and I just
started crying like uncontrollably
crying like everything was going wrong
and I think my mom heard that I was
crying and she came up and she put her
hand on my shoulder and you know asked
what was wrong and four for 10-15
minutes I couldn't even say anything it
was just too overwhelming no so upset
and frustrated disappointed myself I
just cried and the tears are coming down
my face and she just had her hand on my
shoulder and was there for me and you
know after about 10 15 minutes is able
to muster up a few words and even though
she didn't say anything we didn't really
have a huge conversation that night
having her there and having that support
you know meant a lot to me and helped me
get through that that tough night and
and the next day I got up and went back
to work and that's part of being an
entrepreneur and everything I've done my
parents have been extremely supportive
and even the stuff I'm doing now you
know my mom's always listening on the
radio show and watching the videos and
it's getting you know very involved and
again even though it doesn't really
apply to the things that she's doing in
her life it you know they both want to
see their son basics
cessful and they want to have but as
much as possible so thank you both of
you for all of your help over the years
it's meant a lot and I'll never forget
it emotional so for those of you again
you know try to recognize the people in
your life who have had a tremendous
impact on your business on your life
because we can't do it alone running the
business is really hard we need to lean
on people to help us we have to have
people support us through the way if
it's you know financial or ideas or just
a shoulder to lean on I'm sure there are
people in your life had an impact so
thank them you know an email a
handwritten note video like this firing
time today to thank somebody in your
life who's had that impact and that
they'll feel great about it and you'll
feel good about it to thank you guys if
you liked this video you know the drill
thumbs up below and I'd love to hear
from you please leave a comment under
this video let me know who supported you
and your ventures and if you have a
question let me know to it be happy
times for you see you guys soon